Digamos que tenemos esta recta que estoy dibujando
aquí, y nuestro objetivo es construir otra recta
que sea paralela a esta y que pase justo por este
punto. ¿Cómo haríamos eso? Bueno, la forma en que
podemos abordarlo es creando lo que al final será
una transversal entre las dos rectas paralelas,
así que permítanme dibujar eso. Estoy dibujando
una recta que pasa por este punto e interseca la
recta original y queda así, y luego puedo usar
la idea de ángulos congruentes correspondientes
en rectas paralelas. Entonces, lo que voy a hacer
es tomar mi compás y trazar este ángulo de aquí,
lo dibujo así y si dibujo un arco del mismo
radio aquí, ¿puedo reconstruir ese ángulo?,
¿dónde debería estar el punto en este extremo
izquierdo? Bueno para hacer esto podemos medir la
distancia entre estos dos puntos usando el compás,
así que lo voy a ajustar un poco para obtener la
distancia entre estos dos puntos, y luego puedo
usar eso aquí arriba para darme cuenta de que,
aunque me tiembla un poco el pulso, el
punto queda justo aquí. De esta forma,
ahora tenemos dos ángulos correspondientes
definidos por la transversal y las paralelas,
así que lo que puedo hacer es tomar la regla
y hacerla pasar por los puntos que acabo de
crear. Nos aseguramos de pasar la recta por
los dos puntos y se verá así. Acabamos de
construir dos rectas paralelas, y una vez
más ¿cómo sé que esta recta es paralela a
esta recta? Porque tenemos una transversal
que interseca a ambas y estos dos ángulos,
que son ángulos correspondientes, son congruentes,
entonces estas dos rectas deben ser paralelas.